- [ Bobby Lee] He
physically attacked me.
Mike McDonald put him in
a rear-necked choke hold.
Chaos, I'm laughing,
It's fucking hilarious.
(Hip-Hop Music)
(Police Sirens)
(Car engine)
(Revs engine)
(paper flutter)
(Hip-Hop Music
[Crowd Cheers]
- [Ari Shaffir] Thank you.
On this show,
here's what happens,
a bunch of comics tell true
stories and that's all it is.
Ladies and gentlemen,
everyone's favorite Monchichi,
Mr. Bobby Lee everybody!
[Cheers And Applause]
- So, I make bad
choices in life.
And my instinct
is all fucked up.
95% of my instincts is wrong.
[Audience Laughs]
I could be a zombie
apocalypse and just
run toward the
zombies head first.
[Audience Laughs]
Like, I can't even
believe I'm alive.
[Audience Laughs]
So, this is, I was on
a show called MadTV.
It was a sketch show on FOX, and
4th season I show up one
morning, we had rehearsals.
And there was a little white
girl sitting on the couch,
and she's eating
(laughs) yogurt.
I go, "Oh that's nice".
[Audience Laughs]
You need sustenance, you know.
And for some reason,
this is what I did.
I grabbed the back
of her head and
I farted in her mouth.
[Audience Laughs And Claps]
Like just (mimics fart
noise) (chuckles).
[Audience Laughs]
Ugh, it's so
shameful (whimpers).
An actor named Ron Peterson
physically attacked me.
He punched me in
the face, right?
I get beat up a lot.
[Audience Laughs]
And, Mike McDonald who
played Stewart put him
in a rear-necked
choke hold, right?
Chaos, I'm laughing,
It's fucking hilarious.
[Audience Laughs]
But it turns out, that girl
was a new actress we hired,
named Christa Flanagan,
she's really talented.
And so, I go home after
rehearsals and I take a nap.
I wake up and they said,
"You have to get a lawyer
for sexual harassment."
[Light Audience Laughter]
Sexual harassment,
I've never farted in
anybody's mouth
during sex, ever.
That's not a move.
[Audience Laughter]
"That was a great movie,
hunny. (mimics fart sound)
[Laughter]
So they have to get a lawyer.
So Monday, I'm in a law
office in Beverly Hills,
and there's all these lawyers.
And a lawyer says, "Okay,
Bobby tell me what happened."
(chuckles)
Okay so, I don't know,
I show up to rehearsals.
I see a girl sitting
there eating yogurt.
[Audience Laughs]
She loved it.
It looked delicious, you know.
And I grabbed the
back of her head...
[Audience Laughs]
and I farted in her mouth.
There's a 20 second pause,
in the back you hear, "Why?"
[Audience Laughs And Claps]
Like I have a fucking reason.
[Audience Laughs]
Like it's cultural or something.
That's the Korean "Hello".
[Audience Laughs]
When you land in Seoul,
we go (mimics fart noise).
And then, when
happened after that is,
I bought her a gift certificate
to for a massage place.
And I put her on my sketches,
and we're best friends now.
So, that's the story.
[Audience Claps]
Thank you so much, thank you.
[Audience Cheers]
Thank you so much, thank
you, high-five, high-five.
(Electronic Music)